hey 42 here although this may make you
want to smack your head against the wall
repeatedly the fact of the matter is
everything is mouths from your phone to
your house the tiny particles that
everything is made of in the giant
swirling galaxies that dust the infinite
universe all of that is based on numbers
but before you start throwing tomatoes
at the screen as you are part of the
large majority of people who hates
numbers and that evil behavior don't
worry no formulas or tests today it's
changed though isn't it the anger
towards something that is so vital to
our lives and that mathematicians are
seen as strange wizards with their nerdy
number magic so today we look at magic
numbers that rule your life let's start
with a nice safe 110 we all like to it's
the girl-next-door of mathematics you
get 10 you know 10 10 is your friend but
why is this why are we so comfortable
around those lovely rounded tens
twenties and hundreds but it all gets so
murky when you veer away from them well
the simple answer is habit the only
reason we work in tens is because we
have 10 fingers and it just became
common practice to do it like that these
are called bases a base is just how you
decide to group your numbers we work in
base 10 so you have the number 0 to 9
and then if you add one more to 9 then
you complete a group of 10 and so you
move on to the next group so if we
worked in base 4 for example you'd have
the number 0 to 3 and then when you add
one more you complete a group before we
feel like 10 is logical but an alien
society is just as likely to work in
some other base it wouldn't be a problem
though we could easily translate it into
our friendly looking tens many cultures
have used other bases either partially
or completely French for example mixes
in base 20 with base 10 capture avanti
nerf is 99 what translates us for 20 s
and 19 the ark sump'n people of New
Guinea have a base 27 counting system
with each number being named after a
separate body part
which is how they keep track of things
so I'll have ear apples elbow carrots
and belly button slices of bacon please
probably the most important number of
all time is zero it seems like such an
obvious thing tools but it was missing
for many early counting systems the
Sumerians were the first people to
develop a counting system but it was all
about keeping stock of Castle and horses
so you didn't need a number for
something that you didn't have it was
Brahma Gupta an Indian mathematician
from the seventh century who formalized
0 by representing it as a dot underneath
a number
he also wrote rules about how to use it
it reached the West free trade from
Arabia with the Arabian mathematicians
making great advances in many areas of
mathematics the word zero itself is from
Arabic along with algebra algorithm and
average without zero we never would have
been able to create binary code which
gave us computers so life would be very
different today I would probably be
shouting all these faxes from Town
Square somewhere and then maybe burnt as
a witch can you tell me what these
numbers have in common two three five
seven eleven thirteen seventeen ninety
that's right they are prime numbers a
prime is a number that only divides by
one and by itself we don't include one
as a prime now for number format achill
people you might think who cares why
does everyone talk about prime numbers
like they are so important the fingers
prime numbers are like elements in
chemistry they are the building blocks
that everything is made of two three
five these are just like hydrogen helium
lithium so on every non prime or
composite number as they are called can
be made by multiplying two prime numbers
together a 15 for example is free by 594
is 2 by 47 what's more all even numbers
are the sum of two prime numbers 94 is
89 plus 5 the multiplication of primes
major sound like a dull quirk of math
Mattox but it has a very real benefit
for us Internet users security
multiplying two private together might
be easy but working backwards is very
very difficult if I give you a number
and tell you to work out what primes is
made up of you basically have to try out
all the combinations until you find the
correct ones there is no formula if it's
a small number that's not so bad but
when you get up into something that's
hundreds or thousands of digits long
good luck with that so Internet Security
which is active when you see HTTPS at
the beginning of a web address uses this
quirk of mathematics to encode your
sensitive data you need the correct key
in order to solve the prime
multiplication problem each time finding
new prime numbers can be a rewarding
business since there were a range of
prizes on offer with hundreds of
thousands of dollars being offered for
ones over a hundred million digits long
the current record holder for the
world's largest prime number was only
just discovered in January 2016 and the
number itself is over twenty-two million
digits long although we picked him
because of what our hands looked like
there are some other numbers that are
important throughout the universe such
as 3.14 oh hi Carl Sagan the famous
astrophysicist wrote a novel contacts
which became a big movie when humans
find the number pi in a radio signal
from the stars we know it's a sign of
intelligent life because this number
must be universal to everyone regardless
of how many fingers the alien species
has pi is actually quite a simple
concept if you take a circle and divide
its circumference by its diameter then
you always get the same answer because
this is just a ratio that makes your per
circle it's everywhere car tires coke
cans actual pies and Karl Pilkington's
impressively round-faced and it has been
invaluable to engineering advances for
thousands of years pi not Karl
Pilkington's face there are other
constant numbers like E which is 2.718
that is used for many things but fame
I'm working out interest in banking I'm
sure we all have a lot of interest in
banking but one constant that is much
more exciting is fee the golden ratio
the number is about 1.618 and it's all
about proportions take a rectangle if it
is a perfect rectangle then the long
side will be one point six one eight
times longer than the short side the
golden ratio the reason we're so
interested in it is that it seems to
appear in nature all the time especially
when you apply it to spirals the seeds
of a sunflower the swirl of a galaxy
pine cones hurricanes these all obey the
golden ratio you can see examples of the
golden ratio in ancient buildings on a
huge number of paintings it's often been
suggested that it is the number of pure
beauty and that's a face with features
matched in the golden ratio is going to
be the most universally popular of all
so make sure you have a rule about ready
next time you're on tinder even if you
are one of the many people who would
rather like a toilet bowl and work out a
percentage it's good to know that math
is out there doing its job even without
your help and your appreciation young
grateful little monkey and of course
even though it's not on the list all of
us know which number is really the
secret answer to the universe don't we
thanks for the view subscribe for more
and add to free / 7 that's it
subscribe for more 42 normally
governments combat obesity with hopeless
advertising campaigns and even taxing
junk food but Japan went the extra mile
and simply made it illegal to be fat do
you ever hear a noise not a bump in the
night per se but a hot